WATER PISTOL THEY WOULD BE
PRESENTING IT TODAY BUT THEY'VE
GOT NOTHING ON JOE BIDEN.
>> IF WE HAD A BOX OF ALL THE
FOREIGN MONEY THE BIDEN'S TOOK
IT WOULD HAVE REACHED TO THE
CEILING.
>> THIS IS NOT A SERIOUS
INQUIRY.
THIS IS NOT A SERIOUS HEARING.
>> HUNTER BIDEN REFERRED TO
ACCESS TO HIS FATHER AS THE KEYS
TO HIS FAMILY'S ONLY ASSET.
THOSE WORDS ARE GOING TO COME
BACK AND HAUNT HUNTER BIDEN.
>> THE ONLY THING THE PRESIDENT
CAN BE GUILTY OF HERE IS BEING A
FATHER.
>> THIS IMAGE SHOWS AN EMAIL
BETWEEN HUNTER BIDEN AND HIS
BUSINESS ASSOCIATES STATING THE
SETUP OF EQUITY IN A CHINESE
OWNED ENERGY VENTURE.
WHO ELSE WAS GETING A CUT?
ACCORDING TO THIS EMAIL 10
PERCENT WAS GOING TO THE BIG
GUY.
>> THIS IS AN EMBARRASSMENT.
AN EMBARRASSMENT TO THE TIME AND
PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> OH, MAN.
JUDGE, WE HAD TO ENDURE THE
WALLS CLOSING IN EVERY DAY WITH
STUPID ACCUSATIONS ABOUT TRUMP.
NOTHING ABOUT HIM COMES CLOSE TO
A QUARTER MILLION BRIBE BEING
DELIVERED TO JOE'S HOUSE.
I GET IT.
THAT'S WHERE HUNTER LIVED
BECAUSE HE HAD TO PLAY AL MONEY
I.
SHE A MIDDLE AGE MAN.
HE CAN FIND AN APARTMENT.
THIS IS A SMOKING HOWITZER.
>> FOR THAT MONEY SHE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO BUY A HOUSE.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S AMAZING, LOOK.
THIS IS AN PEOPLE INQUIRY.
YOU DON'T MOW THE WITNESS AT THE
INQUIRY.
WHAT YOU DO IS WAIT UNTIL THE
TRIAL.
YOU DON'T ALLOW ANYBODY TO BE
IMPEACHED OR CROSS EXAMINED.
YOU PRESENTED THE MINIMUM AMOUNT
OF EVIDENCE NEEDED.
HERE'S THE AND BOTTOM LINE.
WHAT DID HUNTER BIDEN DO AFTER
THERE WAS REQUEST FROM BURISMA.
FIRST OF ALL HE CALLS HIS DAD
GETS ON A PLANE FLIES TO UKRAINE
AND SAYS GET RID OF THE
PROSECUTOR ENDS UP LEVERAGING
OUR TAX DOLLARS TO GET RID OF
THE PROSECUTOR ON A COMPANY
WHERE HIS SHOP IS MAKING FORTUNE
AND PUT IN A NEW PROSECUTOR WHO
DROPS THE CHARGES AGAINST SOFT
CHEST KEY WHO GAVE HIM $5
MILLION.
THERE IS A POINT AT WHICH THEY
HAVE TO ADMIT THERE'S SOMETHING
HERE BECAUSE IF YOU'RE GOING TO
IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP FOR MAKING
PHONE CALL TO SAY WHAT WAS JOE
DOING OVER THERE THAT WE KEEP
HEARING ABOUT UKRAINE AND NOW
ALL OF A SUDDEN WE KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON IN UKRAINE.
THAT'S NOTHING.
IT'S A THEY MIKE.
>> YOU KNOW SHANNON THIS IS
WORSE THAN WATERGATE AND
ACTUALLY I MEAN THAT BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT CNN SAID EVERY DAY
ABOUT ANYTHING TRUMP DID BUT IN
THIS CASE IT IS WORSE.
HE HAD KNOWLEDGE OF THESE
BUSINESS DEALINGS.
GOD KNOWS WHAT HE WAS DOING IN
UKRAINE.
>> IF WE DIDN'T HAVE THE IRS
WHISTLEBLOWERS IF THE HOUSE
G.O.P. DIDN'T HAVE SUBPOENA
POWER THERE'S A LOT WE WOULDN'T
KNOW.
THERE MAY BE KNOCK TERRIBLE END
OF THE ROAD BUT IN THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS TO KEEP CHANGING THE
STORY DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
IT, DIDN'T HAVE DINNER, DIDN'T
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WHEN THERE
ARE PICTURES OF THEM IT GIVES
THE APPEARANCE THERE'S MORE WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS WHOLE
THING SO ONE WITNESS SAID A WAY
TO EXAMINE IF THIS IS LEGITIMATE
IS FLIP THE NAMES AND PARTIES.
I THINK THAT WITNESS WAS TALKING
IN THE CONTEXT OF DEFENDING
BIDENS SAYING WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6 WAS SOMETHING
DIFFERENT BUT IF YOU HAVE WIRE
TRANSFERS INVOLVING DONALD JR.
AND BUSINESS DEALINGS TRUMP SAID
HE NEVER WENT TO I DO THINK
DEMOCRATS WOULD FEEL
DIFFERENTLY.
IT'S VERY MUCH A ROHRSHACH TEST.
>> LET'S GO THE DEMOCRATS.
MAYBE IT'S JUST AING INTO
BURGER.
>> I COULD TELL FROM YOUR A
BLOCK THERE.
SO TWO THINGS BEFORE I GET TO
TODAY JUST CLARIFICATION.
YOU DON'T DROP A WIRE TRANSFER
OFF AT A HOUSE LIKE A GOLD BAR
LIKE BOB MENDEZ WOULD GET.
IT IS A WIRE TRANSFER.
ALSO THE VICTOR SHOKIN STORY
EVERYBODY WATCHED PRENG OH WHERE
HE DESTROYED THE NARRATIVE THAT
VICTOR WAS HELPING THE BIDENS IN
ANY WAY.
I WOULDN'T HIGHLY RECOMMEND
THAT.
>> FIRST OF ALL JAMES COMER AND
THE REPUBLICANS WERE UNPREPARED
FOR.
THIS THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
RULES QUESTIONS THAT JAMIE
RASKIN AND AOC WERE ASKING
PROCEDURALLY WHICH HE DIDN'T
KNOW HOW TO DEAL WITH WHICH IS
EMBARRASSING IF YOU'RE A CHAIR
AFTER COMMITTEE THERE.
WERE NO FACT WITNESSES OR NEW
EVIDENCE.
TO SET THE TABLE AND NBC POLL
SAYS 56 PERCENT ARE NOT
INTERESTED IN BUT THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN KEEPING THE
GOVERNMENT OPEN.
I UNDERSTAND JUDGE YOU SAY YOU
DON'T SHOOT YOUR WAD OR WHATEVER
ANALOGY ON THE SET BUT IF WERE
YOU TO PICK THREE WITNESSES
WOULD YOU WANT TWO THIRDS OF
THEM TO SHOOT A HOLE IN YOUR
ARGUMENT?
CHARLIE SAID I DON'T BELIEVE THE
CURRENT EVIDENCE WOULD SUPPORT
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT.
DUBOIS SAYS MORE EVIDENCE NEEDS
TO BE GATHERED BEFORE THAT
ASSESSMENT.
IT'S AN INQUIRY.
FIRST OF ALL LEAD WITH YOUR
STRONGEST ARGUMENT BUT THE WHOLE
POINT OF THIS WAS I HAVE MORE
SUBPOENA POWER.
THEY JUST PRESENTED THE SAME OLD
BS TALKING POINTS G.O.P. AIDES
FREAKING OUT TALKING TO
REPORTERS SAYING THIS IS
UNMITIGATED DISASTER AND PICKING
WITNESSES THAT REFUTE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS ARGUMENT FOR
IMPEACHMENT IS MIND BLOWING.
>> NONE OF THIS STUFF WOULD HAVE
MATTERED IF THIS WERE TRUMP.
THAT'S WHAT'S COMICAL ABOUT
THIS.
IT'S SO FUNNY.
I'M ENJOYING THIS.
>> THEN THEY MAY BOTH BE GUILTY?
>> NO.
BIDEN IS GOING TO JAIL.
TRUMP IS GOING TO BE PRESIDENT.
>> JESSICA SAYS THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE.
>> I COMPLIMENTED YOU THOUGH.
>> HERE'S THE NUDE EVIDENCE THEY
PRESENTED.
AN EMAIL FROM JIM BIDEN TO
HUNTER BIDEN.
>> OH THE DOCTORED ONE?
>> NO.
I CAN WORK WITH YOUR FATHER
ALONE.
SO, THERE GOES THE I WAS NEVER
IN BUSINESS WITH MY SON BECAUSE
NOT ONLY WERE YOU IN BUSINESS
WITH YOUR SON, YOU WERE IN
BUSINESS WITH YOUR BROTHER.
>> SO THAT CAME FROM BYRON AND
AOC HAD THE FULL QUOTE.
>> I HAVE THE FULL QUOTE.
>> OKAY, JESSICA I DON'T NEED TO
WRITE IT DOWN BECAUSE I KNOW IT
COLD.
YOU GUYS HAVE NO DEFENSE.
ALL YOU DO IS GET UP THERE AT
THESE HEARINGS AND THROW PAPERS
AROUND AND MAKE IT A BIG SUBJECT
OF RIDICULE.
NO ONE ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE
NOR YOU HAS EVER ADDRESSED THE
EVIDENCE.
YOU'VE NEVER ADDRESSED THE
PHOTOGRAPHS, THE WIRES, THE TEXT
MESSAGES, THE EMAILS, THE
MEETINGS, ALL OF THE ACTIONS
THAT THEIDEN FAMILY HAS TAKEN
AND ALL OF THE MONEY THAT HAS
POURED INTO THE BIDEN FAMILY
BANK ACCOUNTS.
YOU'VE NEVER DEFENDED IT ONCE.
ALL YOU SAY IS, NO EVIDENCE!
THAT'S NOT GOING TO FLY AND THE
REPUBLICANS ARE TAKING THIS
METHODED CALLY AND YOU CAN PULL
YOUR HAIR OUT BUT YOU HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE FACTS.
>> I WOULD NEVER TOUCH MY HAIR
AND WE DO ADDRESS THE FACTS.
WE SAY IF HUNTER IS GUILTY OF
SOMETHING.
>> NOT JOE.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT WALLS ARE
CLOSING IN JESSICA.
>> I ALWAY